¿pueden acelerar ese proceso un poco?
Porque estamos en una crisis climática en este momento.
Y sus ciudades están realmente contaminado, por cierto".
Y respondieron:
"No sé seguro qué has oído acerca de nuestro programa de torio,
pero no tenemos una tercera parte de nuestro presupuesto,
y tu departamento de energía no ha sido muy receptivo
con los datos que obtuvieron en los reactores de ensayo".
Dije: "Bueno, tengo una idea.
¿Uds. saben cómo obtuvieron 10 años al demostrar ese reactor?
Saltemos esa parte,
y pasemos directo a la comercialización.
Eso ahorrará dinero y tiempo".
Y el ingeniero me miró y dijo:
"Déjame hacerte una pregunta:
¿Comprarías un auto que nunca fuera probado antes?"
¿Qué pasa con los otros reactores?
Hay un reactor que viene en línea ahora, están empezando a venderlo.
Es un reactor de gas de alta temperatura.
No puede fundirse.
Pero es muy grande y voluminoso, eso es parte de la seguridad,
y nadie piensa que jamás vaya a ser más barato
que los reactores que tenemos.
Los que usan residuos como combustible son ideas muy cool, pero la verdad es,
que no sabemos cómo hacerlo todavía.
Hay cierto riesgo de que generen más residuos,
y la mayoría de la gente piensa que si está incluida
la parte de residuos en el proceso,
va a encarecer la máquina,
es añadir otro paso complicado.
La verdad es,
hay interrogantes sobre cuánto de eso vamos a hacer.
Fuimos a India y preguntamos sobre el programa nuclear.
El gobierno dijo antes de las negociaciones sobre el clima en París
que iban a hacer algo así como 30 nuevas plantas nucleares.
Pero al llegar allí y entrevisté a las personas
y miramos los documentos internos,
ahora están diciendo que van a hacer unos cinco.
Y en la mayoría del mundo, especialmente los países ricos,
no hablan de la construcción de nuevos reactores.
De hecho, hablamos de eliminar reactores
antes del fin de su vida útil.
Alemania está presionando a sus vecinos a hacer eso.
Mencioné EE. UU.
podríamos perder la mitad de los reactores en los próximos 15 años,
lo que acabaría con un 40 % de la reducción de emisiones,
se supone que debemos seguir el plan de energía limpia.
Por supuesto, en Japón, desactivaron todas las plantas nucleares,
las reemplazaron por carbón, gas natural, quema de petróleo,
y se espera que enciendan de un tercio a dos tercios.
Así que cuando hicimos las cuentas,
y sumamos,
la energía nuclear de China e India,
en los próximos 15 años,
cuánto es lo que vemos en riesgo al sacarlas de línea...
este fue el hallazgo más sorprendente.
Hallamos que el mundo corre el riesgo
de perder cuatro veces más energía limpia que en los últimos 10 años.
En otras palabras: no estamos en una revolución de energía limpia;
estamos en una crisis de energía limpia.
Por eso es comprensible que los ingenieros busquen una solución técnica
a los temores que la gente tiene a la energía nuclear.
Pero si tenemos en cuenta que son grandes retos,
que la solución va a demorar mucho tiempo en llegar,
hay otra cuestión, que es:
¿Resolverán esas soluciones técnicas los temores de la gente?
Hablemos de la seguridad.
A pesar de lo que la gente piensa,
es difícil hacer mucho más segura a la energía nuclear.
Es decir, todas las publicaciones médicas que lo analizan...
este es el estudio más reciente de la revista británica "Lancet",
una de las revistas más respetadas en el mundo,
la nuclear es la forma más segura de producir energía fiable.
Todo el mundo teme a los accidentes.
Veamos los datos de accidentes de
Fukushima, Chernóbil...
La Organización Mundial de la Salud encuentra la misma cosa:
la gran mayoría del daño se produjo por el pánico de la gente,
y entran en pánico porque tienen miedo.
En otras palabras,
el daño causado no es provocado por las máquinas
o la radiación.
Es causado por nuestros miedos.
Y ¿qué pasa con los desechos?
Todo el mundo se preocupa por los desechos.
Pues bien, lo interesante de los desechos
es lo poco que hay.
Esto es de una planta.
Si tomamos los desechos nucleares producidos en EE. UU.,
los ponemos en un campo de fútbol, los apilamos,
solo llegarían a 6 metros de alto.
Y la gente dice que envenena a las personas o hace algo...
no es así, está allí depositado, está supervisado.
No hay mucho.
En cambio, a los desechos no controlados de la producción de energía...
los llamamos "contaminación", y matan a siete millones de personas al año,
y son una amenaza muy grave para los niveles de calentamiento global.
Y la verdad es que incluso si logramos usar los desechos como combustible,
siempre habrá un poco de combustible sobrante.
O sea, siempre habrá personas que piensen que es un gran problema
por razones que quizá no tienen mucho que ver con el desecho real
como pensamos.
¿Y qué pasa con las armas?
Quizá lo más sorprendente es que no hallamos ejemplos
de países que disponen de energía nuclear
y luego deciden ir por armas nucleares.
De hecho, es al revés.
Encontramos que la única forma que conocemos
de deshacerse de grandes cantidades de armas nucleares
es usando el plutonio de las ojivas
como combustible en nuestras plantas de energía nuclear.
Así que si queremos que el mundo elimine armas nucleares,
vamos a necesitar mucha más energía nuclear.
(Aplausos)
Cuando estaba saliendo de China,
el ingeniero que llevó a Bill Gates allí me llevó a un lado,
y dijo: "Sabes, Michael, aprecio tu interés
en las diferentes tecnologías de suministro nuclear,
pero hay una cuestión más básica,
y es que no hay suficiente demanda mundial.
Digo, podemos producir máquinas en líneas de montaje,
sabemos cómo fabricar barato,
pero no hay suficiente demanda".
Por eso, hagamos energía solar, eólica, eficiencia y conservación.
Aceleremos los programas nucleares avanzados.
Creo que deberíamos triplicar el dinero invertido en esto.
Pero creo que lo más importante,
si vamos a superar la crisis climática,
es tener en cuenta que la causa de la crisis de la energía limpia
no está dentro de nuestras máquinas,
está dentro de nosotros.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)